This is very interesting to see.
Republican Senator and Trump brownnoser Rand
Paul went on Fox News this weekend and tried
to pawn off on Fox News host Chris Wallace.
This silly notion that Donald Trump can't
be tried for his impeachment after being out
of office.
Now, remember that even though legally Trump
can be impeached after leaving office, he
was impeached while in office.
But the trial is happening afterwards.
It's happening now.
There's nothing unconstitutional about this.
There's really nothing particularly remarkable,
remarkable about that.
But Rand Paul tries that failed argument on
Chris Wallace and Chris Wallace shuts it down
and rightly so.
Let's look at the first clip.
The other side argues that under that standard,
a president could abuse his power, quit at
the last minute and could not be held accountable
by the Senate for that.
Obviously, if it's if it's a legal crime,
he could be.
But for a political crime, the Senate would
be unable to touch him under your standard.
I think that argument ignores the fact that,
yes, the president can be prosecuted.
And if they think he is inciting a riot or
an insurrection, which is such an overstatement
and such a conclusion without any sort of
presentation of evidence, all the left wing
media just concludes it.
But the thing is, is yes, they can take him
to court.
They can take him to trial and do it.
I think he has suffered under public opinion.
His numbers are greatly reduced.
And so I think there's all kinds of punishment.
But we have to look, we're not a country for
two hundred and fifty years.
And every other Congress thought it was unwise
to keep, you know, going after an ex-president.
So that's actually super slippery of Rand
Paul.
Rand Paul throws together a bunch of different
arguments there.
Now, they're all bad arguments, but when you
put them all together, it sounds sort of like,
wow, that that was a lot of arguments, lots
of reasons why Trump can't be tried now.
But don't let them Gish Gallop you.
Let's actually think through each of the arguments
first.
Rand Paul says if Trump incited if Trump incited
an insurrection, there can be legal repercussions.
Trump could be charged criminally.
Trump could be prosecuted criminally.
He could be convicted.
He could be sentenced criminally, criminally.
Now, that's, first of all, a red herring because
it has nothing to do with the House and Senate.
The House and Senate don't have that power.
The House and Senate don't have the responsibility
of being involved in the criminal prosecution
of a president.
The House looks at actions and asks, did it
meet the threshold for an impeachment?
If the answer is yes, then they impeach.
And then the Senate holds its trial and evaluates
the evidence.
Law enforcement can do whatever it wants,
but it has nothing to do with the House and
Senate.
So it's a red herring.
But Rand Paul also wants to have it both ways
because it's been these same Republicans arguing
for more than.
Four years that you can't charge a president
for crimes committed while in office, it's
sort of like a if the president does it, it's
not a legal defense.
And now Rand Paul wants it both ways.
Then Rand says Trump has suffered enough because
his approval is down as he left office.
That's also a non argument.
It's like being saying, listen, the crimes
you committed were embarrassing.
So we're not going to prosecute you.
Doesn't work that way.
So it's another distraction.
And then Rand Paul says in the past, Congress
chose not to impeach former presidents.
But again, it's factually wrong since Trump
was impeached while in office.
It's the trial that's happening now.
And it doesn't matter that that's how it was
done in the past.
The fact that in the past choices were made
one way doesn't mean it's unconstitutional
to do it differently today.
And that was his main thing, that it's unconstitutional.
So Rand Paul moving the goalposts.
The question was about the constitutionality.
And now he says, well, Trump's already been
embarrassed and you could charge him criminally.
And in the past, we didn't do it this way.
None of that is about constitutionality.
Let's look at a little more.
And here, Chris Wallace, just shut it down.
Constitutional scholars have said that the
Constitution says you impeach and disqualify.
If the person isn't there to impeach, you
can't do either one of them.
And so there are constitutional experts.
Senator Paul, also before my.
That's not quite true.
If I if I may if I may.
In 1876, the then secretary of war, William
Belknap, serving under Ulysses S. Grant, was
about to be impeached for accepting bribes.
He raced to the White House and resigned,
but the House impeached him anyway, and the
Senate decided that it had the authority to
try him and it didn't try them on.
Although a majority sought to remove him to
convict him, they didn't get the two thirds.
But isn't that the 1876 case of William Belknap?
A solid precedent?
No, because we've never impeach the president,
because we always thought it would destroy
and tear up the country and divide us further.
So that's another slippery attempt from Rand
Paul.
Chris Wallace says, Isn't my example an example
of how this clearly is constitutional?
And Rand says no, because that wasn't a president
and doing it to a president would divide the
country.
Why are we talking about dividing the country
if the initial argument Rand Paul was making
was about constitutionality?
It's completely pathetic.
But what is what is sad?
You know, I know I've said this before, but
Trump saying I'm going to run for president.
Wacky people choose to run for president all
the time in many countries.
That's not really the problem.
The problem was that in the Republican Party
primary electorate, you had so many people
willing to vote for Donald Trump.
That was really the problem.
And if it weren't for the Republican electorate,
it wouldn't make a difference.
Much the same way Rand Paul saying this is
unconstitutional.
And then when you ask him why, he says, well,
because we did it differently in the past
and you can file criminal charges.
And Trump was already embarrassed and it would
divide the country, that's not an argument
about constitutionality.
In an in an ideal world, we would have a level
of education and media literacy such that
people would be able to hear that and say
none of what Rand said has anything to do
with the issue of constitutionality.
His arguments are invalid completely.
Unfortunately, as we talked about with the
Laura Ingram case clip earlier, where she
says, oh, we've now the real insurrection
is Biden.
And people watch and they say, yeah, yeah,
the real insurrection is Biden.
The low level of media literacy makes it so
that this stuff actually has an effect and
starts to sort of infect and pervade society.
And it's unfortunately something that is not
easily solvable.
It's going to be a long time until that is
completely, completely resolved.
So it's disappointing, will continue exposing
it.
But beyond that, we unless we really deal
with the educational problem in this country,
that's not going to get fixed.
And it's a cultural problem as well.
It's a combination of the two in these cultural
education.
It's a cultural, educational problem.
And it took decades, as I've pointed out,
for it to get this bad.
It's not super realistic to think in six months
we're going to fix it.
So it's it's an uphill battle, to say the
least.